president biden's vaccine mandate for
companies with more than 100 employees
is not sitting well for some las vegas
business owners victoria saha tells us
how one man made his decision right
after that announcement
although it's a mandate local attorneys
say you do have a choice the three
options are get the vaccine get tested
for covet or lose your job
i'm all cried out
you know i miss the people that i work
with john allen is coming to terms with
his decision his stance against the
vaccine was stronger than his desire to
stay employed at cox communications it's
about
what you stand for if you don't stand
for anything then you fall for
everything allen resigned from his job
thursday evening right after president
biden made the announcement stating all
businesses with more than 100 employees
will need to mandate vaccines i don't
know what's really in that tube
the reading on the tube can say so many
things of ingredients but at the end of
the day were they really you know i mean
inserting into your body
i don't know in fact there are many on
social media commenting saying it should
be a person's choice to do either others
saying this will be overturned but
lawyer matthew hoffman says that's very
unlikely it's fda approved just like any
other vaccine that we've all taken as
kids is a you know in order to go to
school in order to go to college
and because of that they're going to
enforce this and try to end this
remember when making a decision it's
best to get the facts from educated
sources and talk to your doctor
president biden says businesses will
face massive fines if employees don't
comply reporting live from the newsroom
victoria saha 8 news now victoria thank
you